we still have work to do my friend I'm
afraid we still have work to do
while the critic will take an influence
fast we've already seen going to
honestly
it's good to I'd almost show this you
here you are again
I thought such an outcome likely and so
the gears turn once more ever-changing
yet ever the same with you always in the
center I take no pleasure in such
distractions
you
you call it would suffice
[Applause]
as I have said the proxy queen is unable
to hold the audience must be it must be
something important going on to bring
them out of hiding
you
you
finally you arrived to be honest not
great
even the proxy queen is
you
you can't make such demands the safee
acts are the keepers of the crystal
tower this is about more than the
College of City Axl on appeal if bras
could intervene perhaps we should hear
from our newly arrived friend we concur
with Rossum da let us hear what the
adventurer has to say the CPR so Val
Suren claims if this is true the college
shall institute new measures to protect
the tower that is well within our
capabilities and that's supposed to
convince me that as a battery our friend
has proven their mettle time and time
again Russ thinks you should hear about
these deeds Orie Andhra admit our guests
what are you up to Raz endure I will
vouch for this adventurer while I was
blinded by prejudice and hate their
actions saved shimmering
sapien you know me my son rejected the
Queen's decree and suffered the
consequences this newcomer saved rel
until finally Roz must add his voice to
the chorus
no one has served our queen and our
island as well as this adventurer not
even Roz we have heard enough we accept
that the adventurer is trustworthy say
peoc Lana to you listen to what they
have to say I apologize I can't deny I
promise as is sure there are many more
details to work out but for now this one
just wants a very strong drink if you
would wait a moment my friend I'd like
to talk privately thank you for helping
me we never meant on an intern
razzled I'll remove your furry cease
from our throne after all rods has done
for Queen and country you would deny him
this small comfort why cousin Iran
tolerates you will never understand Roz
did indeed
enjoy yourself my friend Roz certainly
plans do